besides as soon as I need that I'll stay
sharp
get your gobs off her shop that's Perth
if you're watching us on YouTube like
subscribe comment
let's get interactive follow us on
Instagram follow us on twitter follow us
on every social all the links are in the
description but also some patreon as
well for sure speak to them about the
page hunting mission one 1k 1k mission 1
kg are you mad
so yeah mission 1k if you don't know get
to know once we hit a thousand pounds a
month on patreon through head and I will
be drop in 2 episodes a week for you
guys so yeah man
and as always grab the SMG merch 100%
links in the descriptions Instagram
Twitter follow us and let's party man
suck in a [ __ ] that's what we do I
was talking randomly to Jay about like
sex part isn't [ __ ] hmm and how like in
my head sex buyers will be so dope
mm-hmm but I feel like when I get there
like I feel like sex is like a headspace
more than anything - no I mean yeah so
like when you're not in that head space
or something throws you out it's
basically you just can't get back in
like save like if you were [ __ ] and
like someone just come up and slap you
in the ass you can't get back into it or
that ruin my whole day so like in my
head for like a sex pie I'm always I'm
ahead of thinking yeah I think I'd like
it like I think I likes to get into [ __ ]
like that but then once I get in there
and the [ __ ] the madam or whatever
she's right all right
have fun and I'm walking in there like
you don't have to stop yeah yeah it's
like when you when you've got like it
you know but you want to clean your room
and rooms a [ __ ] Tim don't know well
you just like where do I just yeah yeah
like that would be me that isn't me
because you've not read it in on a dance
floor where you made connection like yes
tonight zero connect your connection
Ranger everyone's there for the same
thing and everyone's just cracking on
cracking on there and then you just like
what do I do
do I approach it like what do I say to
you first order just like just put my
dick in hey do you want me to hug you
do what like what am i formally
introduce myself do wear a commission
yeah yeah it has to be joining in it and
there's gonna be what's the point and it
like this the thing is was like I saw a
man is there a gay room is there is
there an exploration room where anything
goes over here or do we find out the
hard way it's certain man wanna do man
or man or get on cow or a certain man
only therefore man hmm
like what's going on because if man are
coming - if I give um if I'm interacting
like me and someone are doing our thing
it's my turn and then then sir
a couple munches put a chin on my traps
here I don't go for it and then just
sucking my earlobe I'm I get angry or do
I politely say sir because you liked it
and yeah yeah yeah we can't read again
because you're very gay there for that
reason we in the 6 house yeah you can't
just start throwing bows at people
because there's a lot lips in your ear
lobes to politely say sorry bro lock up
I'm not ready for me yeah or is it then
looks like why you even hear it cuz this
is what is this is what what's what's
what's the etiquette fam I need to find
out it's too much to think about
I need to find out does it differ from
house to house or pie to pie whatever I
don't know it's too much from me from
it's too much I want to do it base just
like I want to do it but the reason I
want to do it don't really come inside
with the reality of it does that make
sense
use one person illegal or like you know
you remember in rush hour rush hour to
where Chris tuck is just a things rush
hour to wait goes to China and he just
got back a Chinese woman like in the
massage parlor yes the pic
that got American man yes in my head
that's my thing is like a walk in there
just baguette yaps on a podium and you
pick you pick and choose who you wanna
[ __ ]
that's a brothel firm this is a sharp
turn from our secretary true maybe
that's maybe that's why I want to go
yeah you want to go to a point one ago
I don't want I don't want Donny's chin
on my traps that's why I don't want
because Rocio I know how I would react
and I'll get you oh now I know how do we
act and I will get thrown the [ __ ] out
firm I will lose my hard-on inside her
it was slider because I can imagine what
my tool would look like getting soft
then I'm just rolling ma'am if pressure
of the palm just pushes it out oh yeah
there were times where there those times
where United too early but you trying to
keep banging alright well so just
because when I had way to Ellie you
don't want her to know so you keep going
but you're getting soft each stroke you
get softer and softer and it's like the
more soft you get the more the [ __ ]
pushes your dick out and you think [ __ ]
and it comes out you try to squeeze the
face squeezing the face has never work
for anyone ever squeezing the base has
never worked for anyone ever face you a
clutch straws in those moments if you
don't know what I do you've got no other
option because there's nothing else you
can do there's nothing I was young I
write the man that just says babes sorry
I'm nice and that's it sometimes I think
I'll just own it
shadows own it and be like only in the
moment not on not own it afterwards not
when you've not I didn't you try and
disguise it and then own it own it when
you're 9 and just pull out uh-huh
yes I've owned it I've owned up to it
before this was before us about tonight
yeah it's like I told her let me stop
because I think we spoke about this
before I don't know if you have let me
stop because the sex that I'm having
with you right now is banging but if I
bust this knot you're either gonna be
very disappointed because it's not long
enough or you're gonna be gasps cuz we
come at the same time but I feel that
more time it's the first one yes purely
because of the length of the sex yeah
when I've not had sexual time or when
I'm like gagging for it or like it's
it's the heat in a moment and I'm bout
to nut and I've gone for a short amount
of time thinking let me stop let me stop
time is up but the more you stop the
more they want it
broan I mean the more yes 21 and it's
like every time I'm trying to slow down
we'll pull out some oh brother
ah the worst one for me is when I'm
trying to tactics now hmm subtle tactics
Oh like I'm trying to pause it so I'm
pulling out nah nothing let me see some
pom for a minute let me go back and she
grabs my chin and pulls me back up and
I'm like you're not you're ruining the
whole thing if I put it back in the
things over done you think I want to
stop oh wait oh you poor thing you think
I want to sell [ __ ] high oh you think
I want to stop feeling any pleasure and
epub and have a sore jaw you think I
want that I have no choice oh I've got
no choice or I'm gonna be digested a
group chat fab group chats having a
chinny-chin-chin tomorrow and I'm the
butt of the joke I have to stop but oh
that's back to sure I was gonna say I
was at a girl's [ __ ] time ago and I
said to wear or I need to stop because
I'm gonna know way too good so I pulled
out no I don't think I told her I pulled
out a knows that are let me go for a bit
like Olivia let me reassess the room
yeah yeah it's like just why you stopped
is not because they care about them they
don't they care about them they care
about them and they're thinking why
would why would you stop what's going on
it is she can come and go again oh it's
over and if I haven't got you there with
my talk I'm not getting you there so far
bro it's done so yeah I pulled out and I
said babe I need to stop for a bit
because this um you know when you're
just about to explode oh yeah yeah yeah
I don't give a [ __ ] just do it just do
it
sure because I wasn't sure whether I
would be able to go again that day or
that period of time yeah we were
together so [ __ ] it just do it
gem she gave me that mic tick of
approval
they don't think when they say
they don't think they do they're still
gonna be vexed afterwards they are but
they just wanted to not stop no matter
what no matter a train could be coming
towards you they they wouldn't want to
stop they need that graphic that it's
crazy but we're not doing it because we
want to do it we've got yeah bro I don't
wanna stop either I just have to show a
sporting we've got no choice
poor little thing I have to stop women
please understand we're not doing it
because we hate you were doing it so the
longevity of this sexism yes oh it's for
you cause generally this is bu they
don't get bro yeah it's funny though but
it'll get be cannot be in the gist of
the group chat when did being like skin
become such a joke when the Viet lice
can be can I answer honestly are you
gonna say we've always managed yeah yo
mum no I want to I want to lock off the
camera if we had a producer when we make
produce some money patreon 1k shout out
hashtag over when we have produced some
money I'm saying to unlock the camera in
these moments lock it and I'm leaving
you've been there Jess I'm sorry I don't
know why I don't condone it obviously
but I'm having a man outside you know
what it was you know what it was this is
my personal opinion yeah we've always
been the joke to the manse yeah because
you might have no choice but to make fun
mmm okay cuz we were cleaning up at a
time yeah we had nothing we had nothing
we had enough James I repeat again we
had nothing that's it sighs you need a
uni times three years one 2012 20 from
property Oh 835 years dungeon not five
years cleaning up when breezy was at his
peak Drake was coming through trey songz
dude on a border
and everything was looking up I'd be
masking was just the way the way and it
was just I just fell into it I just felt
I was ugly but it doesn't it didn't
imitator matter if because ah fam it was
just bliss and then all of a sudden no
one warned us hmm
but I tell you when it started do you
remember when there was that fat Chris
Brown pic but he was on a boat he was he
was in shorts and her stomach on him yes
yes yes oh that big yes yes I think all
this might come out from jail when it
came on yeah yeah yeah it all went down
the hill from there it all went downhill
from there and I was like oh no this is
the beginning of the end because you man
saw it out and fought these weren't a
human these men are human and then from
the tide change the beaches just weren't
feeling us anymore now with the joke
joke from every animal tick-tocks
running rampant with light-skinned jokes
now we're gay guys apparently now we
don't even like [ __ ] we just the joke
that bredda
on tick-tock families the funniest guy
I'm giving I'm gonna give him a shout
he's actually [ __ ] funny what's his
name I have no like VCC he's a waste my
way is so funny it's so fun he mocks us
if you guys haven't seen it on sick talk
mostly I'm sure have tick tock he's
gonna shout at the person now so you
guys make sure you check him out he's so
hilarious
so crow sir man on tick tock I'm gonna
get into tick tock in a second hang on
yeah literally that's it
[ __ ] this governments in City oh okay so
VC is weird
all one word VC is weird is my man stag
on a tick tock and he Gaughan's
light-skinned brothers so funny
him and Joshua Neill Josh Rene was my
funniest person he doesn't go nice can
be honorable mention Joshua no [ __ ]
funny breath there's another breath
setting you that does stuff like Joshua
Neil as well he does more like God stuff
yeah yeah it was a karma B's name but ah
[ __ ] I love to bro I love ya sometimes v
sees a [ __ ]
Josh she knows funny but yeah the ice
cream guys just they
we haven't got no source anymore we've
got zero source
it's [ __ ] infuriating it's
infuriating and we all look found a
think I don't think nowadays it's more I
don't think you're like the digest
anymore I think everyone is [ __ ]
everyone now like mm-hmm you don't you
don't get to have a step up anymore beam
light-skinned isn't a process is an
approach yeah it's the streets are
levels no everyone is let us say bleh
everyone's on that firm yeah when I tell
you who settled to score Asian dance
like Korean dance okay because they're
just cool as [ __ ] yeah cuz they never
get a Shing Donny's never used to get a
look-in mm-hmm and these times win light
skiing went down and Asians went up and
the the tides turned and the streets
were level hmm now no one gets no one
that's it yeah that's it now like no
one's got a pedestal that's the way you
don't get to be buffer just because your
son yeah only one not only counts for
height you're told then you get a leg up
on people and that's just God's grace
there's nothing we can find that we
can't fight that that's a fair play
God's grace that's just God's grace at
the Lord giver to get me that's jokes
but that's jokes yeah in terms of race
Wars the street said nah no more all
lives ma the street said all lives ma
everyone deserves the puss that's funny
yeah but we get God we get gun in the
pantry you all look alike cause it's
true Troy Deeney game needs to stop you
might you know who I'm talking to in it
you can't you know I'm talking to you
this Troy Deeney game a nice toss up you
might think I don't see it I don't
comment on it I don't comment on SC so
for those for those I don't get the
context truly Danny is a football player
that plays for Watford FC in the UK so
for that for the guys that are abroad
and don't watch like English football is
a football player that resemble here is
MJ not resemble me stay well people
that James resembles Troy Deeney so if
you don't know who he is have a Google
and then make your own assessment um
yeah everyone on tik-tok comments
Troy Deeney is making podcasts now back
CEO of traitor CEO of Twitter is if I
look here and I just annoys you know it
isn't that it annoys me because you get
nothing but love
not necessary nothing but love but you
get nothing but I don't get any
discriminate like any form of that kind
of thing ya know you get like who has
laughs this and like laughing that makes
sense this sometimes I'll get a James
this more time Troy Deeney it's true had
this this Troy Deeney 20 new toy Dini
tree is that what it amount comment on
what James put or I can let people aware
that he looks like Troy Deeney yeah
ting is as well I don't I don't
personally look I don't think I look
anything like here but I do think he
looks like my brother I do actually
think he looks like a lot like my
brother which makes me feel like well
maybe does then I've got a story about
your brother that you don't even know
it's so weird but it's go on then go on
so I was talking to Bella this is
probably a week and a half ago two weeks
ago and she didn't hear me say oh my god
how much does James's brother look like
him and then I said him I sent her a pic
of him I think he maybe he I sent I
can't get my words out I sent her a pic
of him from our ships and gigs Instagram
I sent it to her profile that make sense
yes sorry his Instagram Marsh yeah yeah
but she didn't hear me say oh my god how
much does James Bravo look like James
she said when she looked at a pic she
was like she says something in
Portuguese and she tried to explain it
in English her translation was something
similar to it looks like James but he's
been run over by a train
oh well I didn't know she didn't hear me
say oh my God look how much James is
blue as a random Donny funny it was
funny to me and I was like baby did you
not just hear what I just said Oh
I'm not even gonna tell him that I'm not
even gonna tell him that he's gonna be
livid
this is when people catch up and they DM
him yeah they're gonna D he doesn't he
doesn't watch episodes like that okay
his dm's are gonna pop they're gonna see
the surname and they're gonna think
that's him pop oh [ __ ] that's tread she
didn't hear me say look how much she
just well you've sent him on random
doppelganger it looks like James buzz
been run over by a train my jaw hit the
floor James
I couldn't believe not even let's say
she didn't hear me obviously obviously
she didn't yeah I didn't know she had
that inner to be that brutal yes you
know what yeah yeah yeah what shocked me
that I wouldn't even say that I wouldn't
say that I say some horrible [ __ ] I
wouldn't say that I wouldn't be the
first oh yeah right he looks like James
Barr he doesn't I would be like oh
that's a buzz few have like that's the
worst I was saying yeah yeah that's the
worst I would say I would never say
those are flakes got hit by a [ __ ]
train oh my poor look listen yeah my
brother's a camp he's a good man and he
gets his share [ __ ] man don't don't
sleep on Lawrence Lawrence guesses [ __ ]
so I got you boy man [ __ ] Bella that's
[ __ ] it's asking Horry
it is horrible but the thing is I wanted
to tell you mmm
but I wanted to tell you on this putt by
I knew for a fact it's not something I
wanted to write down so I'm so happy you
it came up organically you know I mean
mm-hmm
[ __ ] that was so funny when she said
it's me was so funny bro I was sat there
and she was sat over there or something
I was like surely you heard why said
when I say need a big job and she just
came up with I was like wow bro
random I just I was just thinking about
we was just talking about the the black
thing yeah and I think I feel the worst
do you first of all have you ever
watched TLC the channel on Skyy it's
just pure reality morality stuff yet not
yes and no I have but I can't remember
when man there's a show on there called
thousand-pound sisters yeah never heard
of it thousand-pound sister
it's these two sisters their way like
500 pounds each
when I say they're [ __ ] fat they're
[ __ ] fat they're fat cause they're
[ __ ] fat one of them's got fat on her
forehead
that's how fat she is cuz she's big
she's big I didn't show you a picture
I'll bring it up on the YouTube at the
time as well she she's because you can't
see our eyes for those listen in an
audio make sure you watch this on good
YouTube or Google [ __ ] thousand pound
sisters do you see it she's this is the
ting the forehead - I'm not seeing it
yet so I'm just waiting man this yachts
forehead man not to zoom in man's doing
the pinch and zoom bro
CEO of having no forehead I can't even
see her eyes her eyes can't see a neck
can't see nine
well she's big she's large so yeah
funny thing talk about the black thing
so I'm watching it yeah hmm and it's so
funny that only a certain man would have
this mentality and I wish you were
watching it with me so because I know
it's gonna be funny so obviously she's
talking she's talking they're all doing
their own obvious is a reality to show
we had a TV cousin pass sisters too fat
Tings living their life in it so what
that forehead ting she's talking to her
sister and she's that are basically I'm
trying to this guy and then it sounds
dread but obviously looking at her every
everyone's suspicious about any guy that
she's talking to any guy issues are me
and my she met want tinder or something
so she said she's talking to this guy
that she mount tinder and then they're
like okay cool cool cool and she's
concerned and then they're like oh what
you concern about so obviously he's
trying to meet up and that but like I
don't want him to really know why I look
like kind of thing so what's up horrific
BAM they all might be said don't you
have pictures on there she's like yeah
of course I've had pictures but
obviously and can see what I look like
but when you see what I look like it
might be a different thing in it so
I'm sitting there thinking catfish
they're like no offense
probably a catfish team and she's like
yeah maybe maybe like he's really
good-looking and stuff I bet probably is
luck on catfish
yeah and she's getting depressed on
ourselves famous dregs I'm thinking
that's dread that you're you you see
yourself solo there your automatic
assumption is that you've been catfished
if anyone regular-looking is talking to
you you just think you've been catfished
what's even worse sorry to cut you off
what's even worse when she says she's
talking to a man the bread rinse around
it was like has this man even seen the
pictures bro
exactly that's so peak own sisters
saying that I feel bad fam is Dre I felt
bad so I'm down in the dumps I'm down in
the dumps with her and she's she's out
saying oh yeah it's probably a catfish
cetera cetera so the sister Constitution
she's like let me see we look like
anyway in it so she turns the phone and
obviously I'm looking from the camera as
well which turns to find out and it's
speech for a black brother in it mhm and
my automatic reaction is it's not a fish
it's not a cancer no [ __ ] he likes him
big he likes him be and he was a
passport
that's exactly why once he wants a
possible he's definitely African he's
probably Nigerian any wants a passport
that's what is fam I took one look knows
I was not Catholic
it's no it's not a [ __ ] cabbage
what's the marry again what's the
merrier and he wants to [ __ ] from each
to their own likes that's if that's what
he likes certain a man like I'm thick
thick isn't even the word fanfic is not
the workers when I say thick obviously
we've introduced to think with the quue
when I say thick like that we know we
know what we're talking about that's not
thick there doping doesn't weird there's
like a barrier there's a cross the one
thin line does it see between lines it
can fat thick and fat is such a thin
line well I think I can double on either
side that time red dress was it red
dress or red satin inner
what's the club called in Manchester
that we were at I know exactly
panacea yeah yeah yeah if [ __ ] she was
giving me the most i firm the most this
was a few years ago guys so context
[ __ ] the reserve so i think it was it
was a slot the mandem went out i'm sure
was it just mean you know it was me you
man Toby it wasn't all of us it was me
you know Toby I'm certain of that me and
me Jimmy and Tom's went panacea this was
a few years ago now I think was it an
event it was just a taste with after
sitting so we just went out weren't so
spoke with panacea and it was a group of
I think girls four or five girls that
was like in and amongst our area kinda
take we didn't have a table note we just
wanted dance but they were in amongst
our area and I that plane are thinking
ah this is this is a good opportunity
for all of us the kind of cleanup
crediting cuz it was it was a no you got
fluff in here but it was one of them
which is one of them that's what you
think it can't it can't go wrong yeah
yeah yeah so there was like I think it
was three white girls the biggest girl
was Asian II ish I think and there was a
mango yeah yeah I think I think that was
the ratio hmm so the black girl
automatically like made it clear that
she was feeling me she was she's pretty
as well she was pre she was very pre but
it was one of them ones where the thing
with me when it comes to move into
things and like dancing in clubs or
whatever
I can't I think it was cuz we're so
early in the night as well I can't just
secure myself to one ting at 12:30 yeah
yeah yeah that's early because if I'm
dancing with another ting afterwards I'm
fine with it what is the original Tim
Flannery long don't have that headspace
I'm just here to enjoy myself
so why way my help since I'm a I am a
consequence thinker
mmm-hmm you know I mean I think about a
constant fight I make the action yeah
yeah
so she this and the black girl who was
very pretty
was dancing in front me shaking at ee
it's working in front of me demanda my
writing
but the reason why it didn't was because
I think I was feeling a bredrin the
white team those feeling the effect is
in the bridge if I dogs with this one
that's the other one out the window I
know you feels like do you know what I'm
not even it's not worth it you know I'm
here I know what I want yeah I'm just
gonna enjoy myself with Amanda
regardless so it's a win-win for me yeah
yeah so we as we do we do our normal lap
then we go to the toilet obviously get
the lollipops as you do gang I think
I've got like four or five a sign then
we went back to that same spot we were
at before so I had a lollipop him in my
mouth now and then was it the big tin
that calling me first or was it the
competition between the black king and
their scouts the other thing I can't ask
him specific years ago but anyway I
don't wish what happened first one to
say both sides of story so I was with
the lollipop in my mouth and then the
thing that Jamie was referenced in
Tooting in a red dress I think it wasn't
register wasn't a sky it was a red dress
because I remember that's yes was saggin
sounds bad it sounds bad but it wasn't
it was sexy do you know I mean there was
sign about it that was sexy yeah yeah
yeah I don't know why was why would a
[ __ ] ton yeah oh you know I would have
[ __ ] up I didn't I messed up was you
know over the factor but it was it was
weird because so I had the lollipop
anyway and then she was dancing in my
face like signaling that she wants to
give me a head because of the lot of red
dress was red dress ting she was she was
hanging up yeah she was there was no
nuance about what she was doing I have
never been so shell-shocked in my life
that caught me off guard you know what
to do us both gee I didn't know what to
do and you were saying go for it no I
know and I was like and know where
you're coming from but I do it again
I think about the consequence I don't
wanna ruin my chance anything I like I
felt like it was too early in the night
yeah you're me to secure one ting and
then potentially [ __ ] off everything
else yeah I just wanted to have fun the
most fun I could post yeah
so in hindsight I hindered myself yes I
could have had even more fun yeah I'm a
little idiot anyway that was today where
Baron man this is the same friendship
group so moved on I didn't do a thing
with the going to redress whatever we
were just having fun we were wherever
and then the one that I wanted
originally when the black girl was
dancing with me it was her birthday
I remember it was her birthday so I
think I went up to where said happy
birthday or something something
something and there she was like uh what
do you want what you're gonna give me
for my birthday is something along those
lines like oh you can have my lollipop
gang or something so the white girl
other bugger this is the white gold did
well good faked it yeah yeah yeah yeah
something along the lines of you can
have my I can you get him a lollipop
kind of thing
and obviously that's a that's an
innuendo yeah he took it she licks it
licked her lips and gave it back to me
oh no no before that before that sorry
before that the oh my god I remember the
short asian when the drunk drunk she was
a stainless I remember one with a
[ __ ] brick phone she had a [ __ ]
drug dealer phone
I remember seen that cuz she gave her
number to another brat the end of the
night I remember seeing us making your
disgust gostin remember see you know
anyway it was the black golf was the
black girl that took my lollipop first
Oh clicked it and then a woman who faked
it saw it happen she called me over like
this then we started to discuss about
the birthday thing she then took the
lollipop took it and gave it back to me
I just I took it back off her she was
like oh where's Molly can have a lot of
dad went to get her a lolly came back
and then that's when I tried to pursue
her even more mm I think because she had
seen everything else she was jealous yes
from that one up she wanted to be the
belle of the ball
yeah yeah it was a it was such a wit it
was a dolt day it was weird but I should
have capitalized on one ago and I know I
regretted now I don't really works I
have still had so much fun because was
jobs yeah if it was just us man I'm
gonna go into ridges time ago Oh hunty
time ago yeah if none of them were there
except just red dress go time ago firm
just for contact I didn't even think we
said it this red dress girl was fat oh
yeah but she wasn't she wasn't she
wasn't five she was a 500-pound fat but
she was just over the border line from
thick she was like very very thick three
months ago - I mean three months ago she
was very thick and then she she'd had a
couple months in lockdown it wasn't the
best time for her she had a couple rough
periods and she ate and now she's fat
and but the way she was down like this
is how I saw the night and this is why I
was so angry and thing is with you I'm
100% agreed with you in terms of there's
been times in my life I can't count the
amount of vaginas I've turned down yeah
not necessary I would say turned down
but exactly what you said like it's 11
o'clock at night like I'm not going on
that's like I'm not coming out in there
I did we've had Ravens before that would
happily their aim of the night is to
secure palm as fast as they can sand go
have fun with my boy yeah so if
someone's moving to me when I've just
got in the door chances of me [ __ ]
used to mine are slim slim soon on slim
yeah and slim to none because I'm
assuming you're gonna find someone cuz
if I'm not giving you the attention that
you want straight away I'm assuming
you're gonna you're gonna find someone
else you know I'm not gonna wait for me
till 4:00 a.m. you're just not gonna do
it
so yeah exactly I'm the same as you so I
don't blame you for not not choosing
your horse but for some reason that
night I think it's because you were this
is this is the way I saw the night and
it's why I got so angry so obviously I
saw all of them together and I didn't
think anything and then I saw the black
girl moved to you and she moves to you I
didn't even see a shake of tea isn't
working is [ __ ] but I saw their vibe she
was giving you was so blatant mmm that
I'm just like oh that's that's like so
that's me for that's you said yeah and
I'm like that's calm mmm then I saw the
I didn't even know registers partly a
friendship group okay I saw the view in
the black sing vibe and I was like gang
that just that organic vibe is so gang
because I love I love the same as you I
love sexual tension so when people find
each other attractive and you can see it
and they're just here for the meal of
that yeah I'm not yes I'm like quays
getting some tonight right on the gas
and then I saw the white thing then I
saw I didn't see the hole come here and
then I saw you chatting - the white
thing with the fake T's mm-hmm and
because I'm seeing a white girl fake
titties right now I'm like phrases gonna
fall for that he's gonna fall for that
like he's he's not strong enough for
that you don't say he's a strong enough
for that and she probably gives 10% of
the [ __ ] that this go gives because
this goes trying like she's not be a
desperation anymore vibes over here and
the white goes given minimal vibe I'm
not obviously she was she was talking to
you and calling you every [ __ ] like that
but like she's giving comparison she's
giving you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all compare
[ __ ] over yeah yeah yeah but I could you
see the tease and you don't see my third
person I'm like he's gonna lose oh he's
gonna risk oh oh and he's not gonna get
away one that's so funny and you can
tell just from her energy she was even
if she was feeling you yeah the
pretentious vibe she was giving she was
never gonna [ __ ] you anyway yeah she's
only nice to do it because she wasn't
getting the attention exactly like she I
could tell from her posture that she was
far too pretentious to be founded yeah
yeah to be [ __ ] anyone that Maya so
even if she was down down down for you
that night not gonna happen
you can just tell not gonna happen black
teen hundred it's gonna happen
then I saw red dress thick fat and all I
can see from where I'm standing I'm
standing over here by the bar I'm
looking at her over here I'm looking at
you over here you don't make an eye
contact I'm thinking what's going on in
and then she is just stood up
she had a blinking see a blinking
her tonsils are slapping around this
lollipop I don't figure how
holy [ __ ] well she must have a dildo in
her mouth and she's just staring at you
guys and you you didn't blink either cuz
and I was like oh that's a disabled
toilet thing
that's a disabled toileting this yellow
is that's funny that's funny
well and I was like oh my god and then I
must have said to you and you're like I
know I know I know I was I do that
anyway ting she does well I don't even
know from I never seen that like this
before and then you read na na na you
say if it was just I'll see ya rights
but no no no no and I was thinking it's
so hilarious that I know if if everyone
was blamed you a Scooby warrant dip but
she's she three months past where she
needs to be and it's just like I can't I
can't do this probably be the best on
the sound firms are [ __ ] she's a whip
in the bear he slapped me off and that's
why I said I'm a consequential thinker
if I did I've said it to Bella so many
times if I didn't think of the
consequences I didn't think of the
repercussions I would have fought so
many more people but I'm not I'd rather
I don't know I'd rather dude the good
thing and just go by the right way the
consequences sometimes it's just been me
it's just been in my nature to think
about a consequence I hear you man damn
that red dress story it lives with you
cuz you you wanted me to do that that I
won bro remember I wanted it for you I
know I wanted it for you cuz I remember
and I wanted it as well I don't know I
was like because it was the same Frenchy
group it blew my mind three out of the
five girls it blew my mind you struck
gold that night
I didn't do anything with him I don't do
anything this was years ago I'm so glad
do you do anything with it this is one
of them was I think this as well ways
like I've said this before a lot of the
time it's the chase and the experience
that is more better because you have the
story now if in your head 3 out of 5 gal
we're trying to move to you that's in
your head now that's the experience that
you got but if you were just NAB the
black ting is soon we wouldn't even
remember we wouldn't remember so we
remember it was random walked in saw a
girl she was down did ditch fighter done
and the funny thing is they were they
were from Liverpool so they had to get a
taxi back home that now remember ours
things I asked them if they were staying
in money because obviously I think it or
not you want to [ __ ] something you try
to the lights are on right let's give
anyone in anything from anyone in
anything from when its last calls before
man reached kebab shop that's your
window that is your any man who scoops
up at sing in a kebab shop is a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you've got no decorum no morals you've
got no dignity if you're scooping up
girls in kebab shops don't chat to me
you're not a man you're not a man you're
right you're a rat a leech because if
you can see a ting in a kebab shop with
dim lights and still figure with a
barefoot black barefoot on the greasy
floor therefore is knees all bruised up
for some [ __ ] reason the star was all
over the guy hates there's that's the
one thing I hate when I see on an eye
out girls that can't hack the heels
don't bring any flats and just walk
around town barefoot it drives me insane
don't do it it drives as I understand
don't get me wrong
ladies I understand your feet are
killing you but baby God brings some
flesh bro flats in the cloakroom was
it's literally so would you link Amanda
had barefoot just walking around town
never never
let's just do bats poor man do betters
poor do bad do bad do bad Dube you
deserve what you deserve power also
sorry going back to the the cusp of like
a thick and fat and stuff I think there
is like a middle tier so I
say there's there's so many words I say
thick so I'd say thick as an s th s th
IC ke normal thick or th IC c th i qu e
that's where she's thick thick aside I
think there's too fast there's pH fat
and it's fat fat yes so pH 80 fat is in
between thick and fat with an F so it's
a bbw fat but not poor and bbw because
born bbws fish fat it's fat poor people
obvious that there's no bbw it's just
fat it's just it's literally just like
belly and stuff em they [ __ ] many buns
slight tangent yeah porn loves to
empower people in it it does and it rate
them for that firm I do Rea love to
empower people is ebony this mature that
bbw bro [ __ ] that 14 row none of this
fat [ __ ] old [ __ ] is now dirty
[ __ ]
I [ __ ] that I'm happy for it it gives
people a say of like this is talking
about the people that watch it often lot
of people that do it yeah you think that
watch when it gives them a safe space to
find their actual fetish and not be
judged not be judged and for one also if
it's like for example if we're talking
bbws like because it's not in a fetish
context yeah it allows like if you're a
bigger girl and you're looking at your
like big man there's a hole to agree for
me yeah there's a whole category for me
like I'm not some dirty [ __ ] to know
why yeah
there's are it's not some dirty fetish
thing there's a hole there back up and
out of tryna [ __ ] who don't want to [ __ ]
me bear man that's I feel like that's
the how do I put this I feel like that's
the reason why people are they just own
what they are kind of thing like if a
girl is big and she doesn't get like the
normal day-to-day life as she just loves
herself I [ __ ] with that so I [ __ ] with
that wholeheartedly you know that
reminds me of you know where that
reminds me of what I'm not gonna pay I
know is the the thing the the whining
thing that we saw the video
so there's a there's someone that um
there's a video that we saw an Instagram
over there were like a big girl
just just winding their hips and it's
just the confidence winning just like I
said when you is like if you're you can
be fat just like girl in the red dress
anyone would a [ __ ] gun and wear dress
that night damn a she's fat cuz you
confident with it and you know you're
gonna get the best night you've had the
best [ __ ] ever had I already know I
already know she was suck me dry I
really know so he saw a video of a big
go just wine in her waist the other day
and just doesn't it did not matter she
was fine anymore he just did it just
didn't matter in the first place
but it's just like she's so confident
with it that is actually it's not it's
not that doesn't matter anymore
it's [ __ ] attractive it's [ __ ]
attractive now because she's like big
man my ass is fat we can do it we can
rob yes yes yes yes I know now little
disclaimer mmm four people get carried
away it's like eating themselves to
death if your stomach is large cuts and
your ass is flat I'm sorry I said if I'm
serving you live if I don't want to be
that guy but I'm sorry
GM tink it's not too late it's not it's
never too late but my tools not coming
near you coz I wouldn't get erect it's
impossible for me to get right
impossible I feel bad even bring it up
now I know I know I know but there's a
health issue here because there are some
big girls like you said fat loss yes
they've got a stomach but it got fat it
some fat awesome their bodies just their
bodies just bodies a big boy de you're
me and I want that yeah me and I'm about
and then you got other guys it's like
just girls guys as well guys as well
guys got got guys it's gotta go guys are
the worst when they wear their polo top
and the shoreside you see the beer the
gut just blank that Frank that Frank in
that Jeff no guts are not the lick got
so not the lick ah that beer got not
that bad
one of them your wife your wife should
if I ever look lat my wife should cheat
Oh defecate I'm not the man you married
I'm not happy I'm not because you're
attracted to that you need to work on
you do not I mean if she's attracted to
that she needs to work on herself
that's because that might be the best
you can do like a Barbie it can be fun
surely not it can't be I understand
people change and like once you get
married people change people that just
people feel comfortable read sets there
but don't let it go don't let it go like
that if I met you like that fine and I'm
attracted to that fine I don't have an
issue with that
it's not I don't have an issue with it
the other way because I don't need a
given fight it's not my life is just now
through some minute just do sign about
all right let's do an am I the [ __ ] G
before you find one how can I ask you a
question you ever call your parents
having sex you laugh just just before I
haven't no my parents broke up when I
was very very young yeah I've got a
headache from us but it's funny you
should say that it's funny you should
say that because I was actually thinking
the other day mm-hmm
I was thinking about when you know when
you're a kid I'm with you if your
siblings and you might have just
bragging on each other and then you say
like are you adopted you're this and
then the go-to is like you were a
mistake you know you see to your
recipients you're a mistake you're a
mistake when you're a little kid you
actually don't know what that means
you're a mistake all you know is that
you weren't planned you don't actually
know the semantics of what you're
actually saying I just imagine if
someone said like I can't imagine a kid
just saying like when you're not are you
were a mistake you're a mistake and then
the kid being like mom was like wasn't
mistake
oh he's trying to say you weren't
planned kind of thing he's taught like
don't listen to your office [ __ ]
like saying you weren't planned you know
what do you mean planned like what do
you mean planned and then imagine the
parent block well one night mean your
dad got [ __ ] drunk and he was banging
me he was banging pile driving this [ __ ]
and he tried to stop because he was
gonna knock and I said [ __ ] [ __ ]
call me me and he did and here you are
imagine cuz that's what you're saying
when you're saying you're saying that
your dad Boston in squeezed and family
your type and you know she's fighting
but she just wants it for you
you know her ribs are cracking but she
wants it for you I'm so hot
let me find this [ __ ] thing but yeah
I have a battery call my parents I'm a
sec before but this was when I was lucky
when I was a youth and I he's a yuck of
course I didn't hear what you say yes a
duck yes but I didn't know what it was
until after the fact did I mean because
I was a kid I was probably between like
I don't know I was a kid anyway um you
know we just walk into the room you
don't mean you know you just walk into
the room I don't know why I wanted but
he was on top of her and I was like I
don't know what's going on I don't know
what sex is I don't know why if I even
asked why I wanted to ask but I just
left but I've got that memory in my head
and then I when I started to get older
and that memory randomly came back to my
brain house oh [ __ ] I caught my parents
on sucks
yeah I felt like a lot of people have
quit their pairs over so let me know
guys if you never quit your parents let
me know and let me know if if you knew
whether what sex was at the time when
you caught them or you knew after the
fact cuz if you're catching them now
like grown man now well granted your
parents are active and that's [ __ ]
sick I read that but you need to be
knockin big may you need to be knockin
alright [ __ ] I've loved this
absolutely alright this is relevant
right am either [ __ ] for telling my
sister couldn't sleep because she had
allowed sex as [ __ ] justice I read it
wrong alright I'm 13 all I saw was 13
and I was like what he's 13 my sister's
23 that's a gap what a parents do in
mistake that's a gap that's a mistake
that's why he was he's a [ __ ] mistake
that's exactly why was Jesus and this is
his half-sister and it's a new
relationship thing
I hope so cuz Mike like I'm I'm what 17
years older than my lover makes sense
yeah we've got a great really
relationship and I'm even cool with a
boyfriend last week is supposed to spend
the night at her place that grandma in
this is Tara I can tell you thirteen the
grandma is awful last week I'm supposed
to spend at her place
alright as we haven't seen each other
during the lockdown and boyfriend be
there three sign recent I hoped it would
end soon but they were oh right
sorry I skipped a bit I'm doing a
terrible job right 13:23 staying at his
sister's yard it was all good till their
night activities woke me up in the
middle of the night her flat is large
and our bedrooms are opposite sides of
the hall so that said they meant to be
loud no that meant they were loud
[ __ ] hell this guy's groms awful blah
that meant they were loud cuz he heard
from outside the flan I hoped it would
end soon but they were in for a ride
yuck
I tried headphones with music I didn't
hear them but couldn't sleep with the
loud music in my ear I didn't say
anything is the first night same thing
the next night I was knackered in the
morning afterwards plus I heard her
boyfriend would probably come around
three more times not surprised he's
bossing cause he's coming every night I
mean every night at this point I started
to ponder going back to my parents house
as I've insomnia I couldn't mess with my
entire sleep schedule Tom my sister I
forgot helping my friend with chemistry
my mom picked me up she couldn't wrap
her head around constantly asking me she
Newsline as we know each other very well
she asked her she'd done something wrong
I told her no I would do the same thing
next month while her boyfriend was
abroad she wasn't having it eventually I
thought I couldn't sleep because I heard
them shagging the word shag is jokes Oh
God she got upset calling me nosy and
eventually left earlier she's not
replied to our messages or cause I'm
either also fat end of the real reason
no because he's 13 first first and
foremost months 13 cuz wait young first
and four prior to all that it's a it's a
flat year so is it just dumped where the
rents she's 23 super own yard so why is
he saying he's staying with his sister's
house for a week because they're boys
yeah him and sister are cool okay he had
to ring his mom and said mom can come
pick me up okay I'm not getting any
sleep so the sisters like why the [ __ ]
you leave in you're supposed to be here
a week and these are just of our
chemistry project listen I know he's not
he's deaf inanna yeah tell me why tell
me why so because you were [ __ ] two
loud cars shaggy I couldn't sleep
he's not an [ __ ] now he's not first
and foremost if I'm if I've agreed to
spend time with my younger sibling or
vice versa family if I'm a 13 you're a
boy and I've agreed to spend time with
my older sibling for only a week I don't
think I would invite my partner round
yeah if they don't live they're already
dead to be coming I'm not invited my
part just for his only quality time in
it I mean I don't so especially for his
age and especially that he's he wants to
sleep so he can like be fresh for the
next day to do like he's working
whatever day stuff you say he's got
chemistry whatever he does I I don't see
why she would go off on him bro teen
he's 13 he doesn't need to be banging
lighter as well doesn't he doesn't
comprehend even if she is bagging she
clearly doesn't give a [ __ ] that your
younger brother's in the yard and that's
disrespectful considering he came up to
see you that's disrespectful
yeah so she can't be mad that he wants
to dip it's the truth as well he didn't
say don't [ __ ] he just said I don't need
to be here while you're out here banging
I just don't need it I don't need it
cause
is a real agent she does she needs a viu
if I was the mama class if I like that I
thought holding too much cause if I was
the mom or dad mmm I will cost if she
tries to go off on him yeah if I was
stepping like that stepping like right
yeah yeah so you're doing a [ __ ] job as
a big sister riding since that's you're
doing a [ __ ] job that's fix the [ __ ] up
that's that's an easy one for me yeah
that one's easy I thought I was gonna
get more convoluted than that but that's
grandma I think it the reason why I
zoned up because he's because he's
grammar was so bad he kept on from what
yeah he an [ __ ] cuz you go you gotta
tell it from when he's 13 and she's 23
he's hearing loud sex is she all good as
well even when you're comfortable with
the because I'm everything uni like the
girls that I live with them in my first
year uni before I live with these guys I
live just girls all girls
oh yeah and when I would hear them [ __ ]
if it was weird for me I don't know why
mmm I know what you mean the next day
he's weird weird but I know what you
mean in a weird here when people have
sex is weed unlike any study obviously I
live with ago I lived with Bella so I'm
never gonna make I don't make noise when
he acts yeah me if I'm pounding a chick
and she's making noise that's her
problem
and I mean better in her have to deal
with that that's not my issue yes it's
different for guys it's so different I
understand maybe it's different now
maybe I see this thing different now I'm
how so happy you said that maybe I see
this thing different ah maybe she was
the one maybe she did tell him she told
her boyfriend oh by the way my 13 year a
brother stay with me for a couple for a
couple days just so you know so if we do
have sex
let's try in but my mum probably didn't
give a [ __ ] you know I mean why he was
back it was just because he knows he's
not gonna make noise
she can still stepping in love stop saw
saw saw stops I know she's feeling this
trust what she's feeling that stroke
stroke she's like [ __ ] it
that's her busy one that's her business
it wasn't one night though nope I'm
saying bush and the times door it's only
one night so because we don't have her
back story of it yeah
still times those still times if she
tried to explain that to me hmm I'm was
like I know but the dick was so good I
just I was a shot to the
thirteen-year-old boy no but I'm saying
to me person and I'm hearing his side of
it I'm gonna hear in her side as soon as
I hear that I say sharp get your gobs
off her sharp
[ __ ] hell
let's get your clothes off and shower I
want to partake in that tea ah found
this wrap it up and Jesus guys we'll see
you next week [ __ ] I'm sorry about my
life I'm allowed laughs Jesus Christ